you need protein okay here we go now
what am I doing wrong I need protein how
do you know what I need dear Billy Burr
I heard you talk recently about your
breakfast and getting into shape and
whatnot an espresso and an orange really
yeah really I'm on the road you
um do you realize that as a man
in his 50s which I am as well that you
need at least 1.6 grams of protein per
kilo of body weight to ensure you
maintain proper muscle density let me
ask you this do you know that you don't
know that you just read that and now
you're puking it back to me lean meats
are great like chicken fish and turkey
oh are those great how do you know
they're great you don't even know what
the is in what you're reading sir I
live in the United States of America our
food is Poison the FDA was infiltrated
by everyone that it was supposed to be
watching and they just pass it they feed
cows the cows this man-made salmon
sitting in maggots or whatever the hell
I don't even know what I'm eating